[Music]
[Laughter]
so depending on how much time all of you
spend on YouTube this may or may not be
the first time you're meeting Micah but
what most people don't know is that
isn't just a blank piece of paper it's
actually one of the many rejection
letters Micah's dad received from
potential employers and although Micah
can't walk or talk or even think really
doesn't mean we don't have anything to
learn from him in fact I think his
ability to express pure joy in a moment
that is otherwise quite tragic perfectly
captures what I want to talk about today
that it's time we start taking left or
seriously and I'm not just talking about
laughter as a distraction or a feel-good
activity or a form of entertainment even
though it is all of those things I'm
talking about laughter as a powerful
tool that individuals and organizations
can use to boost happiness creativity
and productivity that's the average
number of times someone Micah's age
laughs per day in adults over the age of
35 we are in the midst of a laughter
drought and nowhere is this more
apparent than in the world of business
although we are somewhat spoiled here in
Silicon Valley the reality of corporate
America is still very much that of rows
and rows of off-white cubicles silent
except for the mindless clacking of
typing or the sputtering of an espresso
machine if we're lucky we are more tired
more stress more miserable than ever
before half of us at any given time are
unhappy with our current jobs and this
isn't just a touchy-feely issue our
disengagement costs the US economy
three hundred and fifty billion dollars
in lost productivity something happens
to us when we start working we start
seeing work as this thing that depletes
our energy and our happiness that we
then need to replenish on the weekends
or during vacation but even in my very
very young career I've seen the power of
turning this thinking on its head when
I'm in a meeting or a brainstorming
session or trying to survive a group
project nightmare and people are
laughing and enjoying themselves and
losing track of time and still producing
good work there's no better feeling and
no greater validation that I'm doing
exactly what I'm supposed to be doing
now it's foolish to think that any one
approach or solution is going to
re-engage the entire workforce and close
that 350 billion dollar gap but I also
think there are small steps we can take
as individuals and teams to begin
chipping away at the problem and as
someone who measures the success of a
day and in many ways the success of my
life in laughs laughter is for me a
natural place to start think about the
last time you had a really good laugh
and I mean a real laugh not a giggle or
a chuckle or those times you say that
was funny but didn't really mean
anything I'm talking about a laugh that
made you cry that made the muscles in
your stomach hurt where for a few
moments you lost complete control of
your body and your mind was completely
clear didn't it feel so good
clearly she she believes that laughter
has a profound impact in fact on our
brains and our bodies it causes the
release of endorphins our natural
painkillers it lowers stress hormone
levels lowers blood pressure relieves
muscle tension and in some cases even
stimulates white blood cell activity a
study here at Stanford also found that
30 seconds of deep belly laughter is
equivalent to 10 minutes of strenuous
rowing when it comes to its impact on
our heart rate so if like me you've ever
wondered if you can scope the six-pack
while I don't know watching reruns of
Seinfeld in your underwear all weekend
if the answer is yes yes you can but
beyond its impact on our bloodstream in
our brain stem laughter impacts how we
think feel and behave
that should make anyone at work take
note another study out of Wharton found
that individuals primed to laugh before
a complex task exhibit not only more
flexible creative decision-making but
also greater analytical precision
laughter truly engages the whole brain
and even when this laughter is forced
when the people were literally forced to
recreate the muscle movements and breath
patterns associated with laughter they
became more optimistic had greater
perceptions of self-efficacy and felt
more connection to their social groups
and these effects remain 90 days after
the forced laughter occurs
it seems so counterintuitive I know but
laughter is in many ways productivity is
greatest ally it clears the mind and
improves focus it relieves boredom and
reduces the need for us to seek constant
distraction entertainment out of work it
reduces tension and facilitates social
connection these are precisely the
qualities that organizations should be
cultivating in their people yet these
same organizations find themselves
deeply afraid to laugh and that's
because lurking in those off-white
cubicles are the enemies of productivity
their song is waiting to be played and
chats waiting to be had and photo is
waiting to be filtered their blogs and
tumblers of Hillary Clinton texting and
Claire Danes crying waiting to be
scrolled through their videos of
sleeping puppies and kitties waiting to
be watched but what if we stripped
ourselves of this fear what if every
week we challenged every employee to
find the stupidest random thing on the
internet and send it out to the entire
team what if like Zappos we encourage
our customer service representatives to
be themselves and to delight those
customers with jokes and stories and
surprises what if like Hulu we gave
every new employee a nickname held
regular taco eating contests and stocked
our offices with custom-built arizuka's
that's near Zuka in case you're
wondering what if like IBM or Yahoo we
didn't number our meeting rooms but
instead ask our colleagues to meet us in
my network or kajagoogoo or MC Hammer or
what if like Southwest Airlines we
allowed our stock symbol to say
something a little bit more about
ourselves as a company I know from any
of you in this room these aren't
groundbreaking and they may even be
played out but for many companies in
this country and all over the world
these would be huge steps forward and
note that incorporating laughter and
humor into the workplace knows no bounds
of industry or size or geography and
notice that it doesn't necessarily mean
turning your office into a circus it's
about doing it in a way that feels right
and authentic to what you and your
companies stand for and finding that
place where laughter and productivity
converge to create magic for some of you
that may mean having silly
putty and slinkys and magnetic poetry
laying around your cubicles for others
it may mean holding regular office
retreats and off sites with your team
for others it may mean rotating funny
quotes in your email signature or
holding meetings where people are only
allowed to communicate in pictures and
gestures whatever it is find it try it
make it a routine make it a tradition
and let laughter in if any one we do I
think we in the communities and
organizations we inhabit will be happier
more creative and more productive when
you leave here today think about what
laughter might look like on your team in
your company in your life how will you
communicate differently spend your time
differently recruit and hire people
differently so that laughter and humor
become an organic part of your culture
and outside of work ask yourself am i
laughing enough am i giving others
around me the freedom to laugh and am i
intentionally seeking out opportunities
to find wonder and humor in my everyday
life the way mica does when he's ripping
apart a stupid piece of paper and when
it does strike when you have that
perfect moment of clarity that comes
with a good laugh please don't be so
quick to forget where you were and who
was there and how good it felt thank you
so much
you
[Music]